the damas is nicknamed the pearl of the
desert
its crown jewel this oasis called rasuf
meaning head of the valley is believed
to be more than four thousand years old
water tunnels fed by the results
stretched throughout the city
have supplied houses mosques and farms
for centuries
after the gasuf was found the city
became an economic hub for caravan trade
connecting countries across africa
and it came under control of the roman
and byzantine empires
but later islam flourished throughout
north africa
this mosque is 1400 years old
the old city is one of five unesco world
heritage sites in libya that are on its
endangered list
the people of gadames were surprised and
have suffered greatly due to the unesco
decision to enlist the old city to its
endangered list the city's economy
relies on tourism so we hope that unesco
takes us off the list so people feel
safe to come and visit
people here say thousands of foreign
tourists used to come and visit but the
years-long conflict in libya has had a
devastating impact on the tourism sector
formerly a thriving city its narrow
alleyways are now mostly deserted
but some domestic tourists still come
these men are from the tuata tribe and
visiting from obadi deep in libya's
south
we were in a nearby village so we
decided to visit this historical city as
libyans the old city links our history
to our present and future it is an honor
to visit the city and to see our friends
from ghadames
it's beautiful to see that the local
community is trying to preserve it
for centuries radham has thrived its
markets and alleyways visited by people
from around the world
but for more than a decade conflict in
libya has kept foreigners away
now people here hope they'll return if
peace can be achieved in libya
and the pearl of the desert
won't be forgotten malak trainer
al-jazeera radames